the stage is set world's will live
worlds will die and the universe will
never be the same
[Music]
everybody is Charlie we have to freak
out about crisis on Infinite Earths so
there's so many Easter eggs to talk
about from the episode but that post
credit scene is probably what most
people are gonna be talking about all
through next spring and next summer
because they just confirm what they're
doing for next year's crossover and they
are going big so don't worry we'll spend
a lot of this video talking about that
there's a new round of that flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
the video starting with number 10 dig in
intro narration they do that funny thing
where somebody else gets to do the intro
but Deegan uses The Book Of Destiny to
create a very injustice gods among us
universe where he's Superman and if
you've ever read any of the injustice
comics or you played any of the games
everybody views him the same way that
they view injustice Superman they even
use killer frost to make fun of him when
she's talking to Alex later in the
episode like we're all here to just prop
his ego up the way they explain it is is
that most of the good characters have
turned evil and most of the evil
characters have been turned good like we
get the teaser at the end of the last
episode where all the police officers
are the villains from the show's number
9 Oliver's the first to figure out that
his Deegan and plays the villain making
Deegan choose whether or not to save the
people in the weird thing about this is
is that he's not just being a tyrant he
actually believes that he's protecting
people so he does go to try and save
them and they praise like yay Superman
saved us but they sort of take the wind
out of them being evil by having Barry
almost throw up that's their way of sort
of bringing it back from the brink a
little bit like this isn't getting too
dark because Barry will literally throw
up if you try to make him do something
evil but the really important thing in
their exchange is that speech where they
T up the whole concept of the crossover
you can't make yourself a hero you
become a hero in spite of your
circumstances you can't create the
circumstances that will turn you into a
hero which have you been watching my
spider-man far from home videos Mysterio
is the big villain to that movie Jake
Gyllenhaal's playing him their speech
about making yourself a hero is
basically a spoiler for Mysterio in
spider-man far from home if you're not
sure what I'm talking about just watch
one of my recent spider-man far from
home videos where I kind of explain what
they've been teasing for that but number
eight we go back to STAR Labs and we see
it's basically the sons of Batman from
the nightmare vision
in Batman V Superman brought to light so
this is more Batman V Superman Easter
Egg they had a brief one in last night's
episode with John Wesley Shipp where he
was reaching through the portal trying
to talk to them just like the flash was
during Batman V Superman they make a
joke about earth to Sisko being a bit of
an [ __ ] he's talking about reverb the
ponytail version of Sisko that was
killed by a zoom a long time ago seven
the monitor takes them to his
observatory if you don't know where this
is the monitors space encircles the
entire DC Multiverse it exists in the
layer of reality between where the new
gods live apocalypse and New Genesis
you're talking about Darkseid you're
talking about hi father
Orion mr. miracle and on the outer edge
is the source wall so the monitors are
kind of like the watchers of the DC
Universe that's why they live on the
outer edge of the multiverse so that
they can observe everything that's
happening in every single reality it was
also a joke later in the episode about
Superman running into beings that could
rewrite reality you're talking about
characters like mr. mrs. pit lik I think
I'm pronouncing that right that exists
on higher dimensions so they can
manipulate lower dimensions like the
third dimension or the fourth dimension
of time in a much more powerful way so
the monitors kind of exist in that way
that's what makes them so powerful as if
they're higher dimension beings couple
funny moments with Barry correcting his
pronunciation of Super Man it's actually
just one word Superman they go to the
dive bar we meet the evil version of
Cisco there's a cool legends of tomorrow
cameo its Gary from legends and even
though reality has been completely
rewritten so everybody's destinies have
been changed this version of Gary still
has pretty much the same personality
that he does on legends he's a big fan
boy ah trigger twins I'm a huge fan of
yours I talked about them in my video
last night the trigger twins are also a
team of gunslingers from the comics that
are just a super deep cut even though
Jimmy Olsen is able to kick their butts
later he also makes a comic book
reference when he says that he's Jimmy
Olsen Superman's pal that's just an
easter egg for that actual comic book
Cisco dropped the Pet Shop Boys
reference and A Clockwork Orange
reference before he gets them to breach
to the fortress of solitude so number 6
Barry Cisco and Oliver in the fortress
on earth 38 if you didn't see it they
were posting funny behind-the-scenes
pictures I imagined that this is what
Superman and Lois Lane were doing before
they showed up they make a whole bunch
of reference
they show the special hammer I'm not
sure which comic book hammer this is
from the DC Universe but it does give
them the ability to disable people's
powers within a small radius of area so
even though they use it against Deegan
it's not necessarily just a weapon to
get rid of Deegan it probably works on
everybody with powers but cisco makes a
joke about him having special objects in
the fortress superman has all kinds of
magical and weird things in the fortress
just like Batman has all kinds of
trophies in the Batcave
number 5 Superman vs. Deegan Superman
there was a great bizarro reference are
you bizarro you know they fight each
other and there's rumors that they're
trying to develop a Superman TV show
with Tyler hoechlin and this Lois Lane
like we found out that they're pregnant
at the end of the episode it sounds like
if that show ever does get off the
ground it ends up happening it'll be a
version of them being a family with
young John Kent Superboy so it'll be
more of a Superboy in Superman TV show
instead of being more like the next year
on Smallville like he had just embraced
his destiny on Smallville like imagine
him just being a regular Superman for
the next whatever many seasons them
doing a version of John Kent Superboy
would be way different and actually
sounds pretty interesting based on the
twist that they introduced those last
five minutes of the episode but we'll
talk about that in a second now all the
Superman stuff is separate but they're
clearly trying to backdoor a Superman
pilot in this for Deagan Superman goes
full Man of Steel on Bertie gettin ready
to snap his neck just like Zod they took
a whole lot of shots at the DC EU in
this number three though Barry and Kara
used the Christopher Reeve Superman
ending to try and slow down time the
thing about this too is that it also
becomes an easter egg for the end of the
comic book crisis on Infinite Earths
where the flash dies because he runs
around the monitor's weapon so fast that
he turns into pure energy and seemingly
quote-unquote dies even though really
flashes don't die that way they just
become part of the Speed Force because
their bodies turn into pure energy
but when Superman's talking about the
vision that he had reading the book of
Destiny in seeing them dying that was
what he was witnessing and it's an
easter egg for crisis on Infinite Earths
in the comics because that's when they
killed off one of the versions of
Supergirl that's what this iconic pose
is from because she died during that big
event so obviously
because we know now that they tease
crisis is gonna be the next big
crossover they're gonna be laying in the
Easter eggs real thick but Brainiac five
Martian Manhunter and Lois Lane with the
special hammer breach in from Earth 38
thank you for including me this time
there was a great Brainiac line and I'm
so happy that they at least included a
little bit a Martian Manhunter here's
the thing though remember this Oliver
had to trade something to balance the
universe to get the monitor's help to
prevent them from dying because that was
their original destiny and they changed
destiny but there has to be balance and
even though they never told us in the
episode what he offered in exchange
think about it this way a life for a
life
Oliver probably said that he would give
his life in their stead and they might
wind up killing Oliver off during crisis
on Infinite Earths but here's the thing
about that the problem with them killing
Oliver off is is that how do you explain
what happens to Stephen Amell on the
arrow TV show if arrow gets renewed for
a next season then you can't get rid of
your lead halfway through the season so
just keep that in the back of your mind
what was it that Oliver traded for their
lives it just makes sense that he would
trade his life but that causes a lot of
practical problems in real life with the
way television works with their lead
actors number two though this is a
really really big one Superman and Lois
Lane are having a baby that's Jon Kent
he's in the comics right now if you
haven't been reading rebirth they've had
a super Sons comic he's been all over
the place they've tried to do all kinds
of stuff with the character so they
basically say that they're gonna go to
Argo city for the duration of her
pregnancy and whatever his young life is
going to be I think this is them just
stating those characters until next
year's crossover or if they are able to
get a pilot off the ground and they get
a Superman TV show on the CW then
they'll bring them back when young
Jonathan can Superboy is old enough to
actually be a character on that TV show
so their show would basically be them a
married couple raising their young
Superboy however old you want to make
him but they also have the scene from
Superman to where Superman proposes to
Lois Lane by crushing the diamond and
giving it to her and because next year's
crossover is gonna be more than nine
months she will have already had that
Superboy baby so maybe we'll get to see
that too during next year's crisis
crossover
number one though we got to talk about
this crisis teaser at the end so they
have beers just like they did at the end
of the previous crossover I think it was
two years ago they haven't done it every
single year but sometimes during the
crossovers they'll end it with Oliver
and Barry just having beers with each
other they get the call from Batwoman
that Deegan who is now an inmate at
arkham it actually looks like comic book
doctor destiny that's why his face was
all messed up at the end because that's
what comic book doctor destiny looks
like he's made friends with
psycho-pirate in psycho-pirate recites
the tagline from crisis on Infinite
Earths
worlds will live worlds will die and the
universe will never be the same that's
from the one page ad the DC ran when
they were getting ready to start crisis
on Infinite Earths and you get that
wonderful looking crisis logo coming
2019 which means you know fall of 2019
next year's crossover now the reason
that says fall 2019 actually makes me
wonder because technically right now
we're in the winter this is the holiday
season when crossovers happen so what
they might do next year across all the
shows is do like a season-long crisis
crossover or at least maybe like half a
season but more than just the regular
three episodes that you would usually
see here's the thing though that flash
newspaper says that happens in the year
2024 and next year is going to be 2019
why are they condensing this time I
think it's because some of these shows
are getting ready to go off the air and
they want to do their big crisis
crossover before that happens so if you
wonder why they're breaking their
timeline because of this newspaper stuff
they'll probably find some way of
explaining that later this season on the
flash like time will change somehow and
the date on the newspaper will change to
match next year's crossover that's a
whole bunch of Nora reverse-flash stuff
so I'll talk about that during my flash
videos but let me know in the comments
what was your favorite moment and post
all your crisis predictions for the
crossover in the comments below
well I'll be freaking out about this for
a while there's a whole bunch more stuff
happening this week you can click here
for my non-spoilery aquaman review and
you can click here for all my other
crossover Easter egg videos thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]